wir rufen den katastrophenfall aus
[Musik]
das corona virus verändert das leben
dramatisch
experten sagen das sind 60 bis 70 der
bevölkerung infiziert werden ich
befürchte das ganze wird uns noch lange
zeit bleiben
es gibt keine therapie und es gibt auch
keinen stoff
es muss unser ziel sein jede
infektionskette verfolgen zu können
wir spannen einen finanziellen
rettungsschirm für unsere krankenhäuser
auf wir helfen wo wir können an
vorderster front wenn diese
unbegründeten hamster einkaufe aufhören
würden dann gäbe es auch überhaupt keine
versorgungsengpässe
wir haben alle um unsere jobs einen
scheiß angst
man fühlt sich schon auch allein
gelassen
zum schutz vor wie die polizei dazu auf
sich auf direktem wege nach hause zu
begeben
[Musik]